Of course, in Christ alone, the
scapegoat and goat that was slaughtered
is a picture of
Christ. Let me answer that real quickly.
Okay. In Christ alone, the function of
the scapegoat was what? The function of
the scapegoat. I'm going to answer these
two questions. Bear with me. 16:11, I
want to answer this as well because it
coincides with Good Friday. In Leviticus
16, you had two goats. The scapegoat and
the goat that goat that would be
slaughtered to make national atonement.
Atonement for the entire nation. The
scapegoat is the goat that thy priest
would place his hand on and pronounce
all the sins of Israel. And then they
would send him into the wilderness
carrying away the sins of
Israel. And the goat that was
slaughtered was slaughtered in the place
of the Israelites dying the death they
deserve so they could be spared. So is
Jesus the slaughtered goat or the
scapegoat? He's
both. He's both. Why? Because what does
the scapegoat represent in pronouncing
the sins of the people? on the scapegoat
and then sending him into the
wilderness. What does that
represent? What is we well we know it's
the sins. The sins is pronounced on the
scapegoat. But what does that
represent? We know it's atonement. Think
more a little more deeply in Christ
alone. Think a little more
deeply. Yes, Walter Jesus. Your sins
being removed and taken away from you.
your sins being taken away from you and
removed from you. Your sins being
carried away. Praise God you guys
answered. Sam Samson. Yeah. So Jesus
does both. He dies in your place to take
away your sins. But you can't have one
goat doing that. Do you know why? You
can't have the goat that's slaughtered
being sent into the wilderness with your
sins upon it because it's dead. So
that's why two goats were required.
Yes. That's where the scapegoat comes
from. You blame someone else for your
mistake. Are you with me
there? Are you with me? Why two goats?
Because how can the goat that
slaughtered in your place, dies in your
place, be sent in the wilderness with
your sins? Can't. Right? So, you need
two. One that dies in your place and the
other one that carries your sins as a
sign your sins have been removed, taken
away from you. That's why two goats. It
takes two goats to do the work of one.
the Lord Jesus Christ. Thank you, Greg.
May he bless you and protect you, too.
Making
sense. It takes two goats to do the work
of one, the Lord Jesus Christ. Jesus
dies, but he lives forever more. And his
death removes and takes your sins away
because he carries your sins and takes
away your
sin. You shouldn't attribute it to
Barabus because Barabus is not an
innocent goat. Barabus is someone in sin
who needs the Lord to die in his place.
Right? But there is a sense in which
Barabus does function as a scapegoat
Samson. So here you're bringing in
another related issue. But you I don't
want you to be confused. Barabus is not
the scapegoat. But Barabus does play out
the role of the
scapegoat in the sense that what you
have taking place at the trial is the
day of atonement being fulfilled before
our eyes. So that Barabus is a type a
picture of the scapegoat but he's not
the scapegoat because Barabus doesn't
take away your sins. Jesus does. Are you
with me there Samson? Who takes away
your sin? Barabbus or Jesus? here. John
1:29. John
1:29. But I'm gonna unpack what you just
said. And I hope I'm not confusing you.
If anyone's confused, let me know
because I want to clarify until you get
it by the grace of the triune God. John
1:29. Here is Protestant here. So you
can post
it. Okay. Then the next day John seeth
Jesus coming unto him and saith, Behold
the lamb of God which taketh away the
sin of the world. Barabus doesn't take
your sins away. Jesus
does. But Barabus
does fulfill a
role. In other words, the day of
atonement is being played out before
your
eyes
in Jesus and Barabus. So, let me explain
this, guys. Now, here's where I need you
to listen cuz it's
deep. On the day of atonement, you had
two goats. the goat that would die and
the goat that would be sent into the
wilderness bearing the sins of the
people of God. On the day of Jesus's
crucifixion, you had two
Jesuses. Two Jesuses. One who was
sinless, one who was in sin and walked
away with his sins. the one who walked
away in with with his sins. He's not the
scapegoat in that he doesn't take away
your sin, but he's playing out the role
of the scapegoat in order to bring the
day of atonement into complete perfect
fulfillment and
fruition. Are you with me
there? Thank you,
Jake. Now, why did I say Barabus is
Jesus? There were two Jesuses. Because
we have ancient manuscripts and an
ancient tradition that says Barabus's
name was Jesus Barabus. So Protestant,
do me a favor. Go to Matthew
27:16-19. Quote it in the NIV, New
International Version, and give me one
second. Excellent question. And it deals
directly
with the topic right now. Matthew
27:16-19. Matthew
27:16-19. Okay. Right here, guys. Read
with me. NIV. At that time, they had a
well-known prisoner whose name was Jesus
Barabus. So, when the crowd had
gathered, Pilate asked them, "Which one
do you want me to release to you? Jesus
Barabus or Jesus who's called the
Messiah?" for he knew it was out of
self-interest that they had handed Jesus
over to him. While Pilate was sitting on
the judgment seat, judgment seat, his
wife sent him with this message. Don't
have anything to do with that innocent
man, for I've suffered a great deal
today in a dream because of him. Jesus
innocent. Another Jesus, a criminal
condemned in a sin. Who does he release?
Jesus Barabus. Now folks, you guys
already knew this because I saw your
comments. Barabus is the Greek
transliteration of the Aramaic bar
aba. Baraba is Aramaic for son of the
father. Bar
aba. Okay, bar aba, son of the
father. So now notice you have two
Jesuses. Both of them are baraba, the
son of the father. You have the true
Jesus, the son of the father, and the
sinful Jesus, the son of a father. Is
that a
coincidence? Or is this deliberately
designed for there to be two Jesuses,
one of whom is called son of a of a
father? Because these are the two goats
of
Leviticus. Even though Jesus Barabus is
not literally the scapegoat because he
doesn't take away Israel sins, Jesus
doesn't. He's still placed there in
order to play out the two goats of
Leviticus
16. Are you with me
there? So everything is perfectly
fulfilled in Jesus. Even the two goats
of Leviticus 16. Right now let's go to
Mark 14:33-38.
Mark
14:33-38 to see bar abus is Greek for
son of the father. Bar son aba and let's
see what Jesus calls
God. Let's see what Jesus calls God. He
took Peter, James, and John along with
him and he began to be deeply distressed
and troubled. My soul is overwhelmed
with sorrow to the point of death. He
said to them, "Stay here and wa keep
watch." Going a little further, he fell
to the ground and prayed that if
possible the hour might pass from him.
Aba, father. Aba,
father.
Aba. Bar. Aba. Barabus. Jesus. Barabus.
Jesus.
Barabus.
Clear. Is it Did it sink in? Did you
guys get this
point
clear? Jesus Barabus. There's two
because they're playing out Leviticus 16
to a tea. Two goats. One sent away with
sin, the other slaughtered for sin.
Jesus Barabus sent away with his sins
symbolizing that goat that carried the
sins of the people. And Jesus the sin
was a sinless one dying even though
Jesus Barabus is not literally the
scapegoat. All right. Anyway, everyone
clear? Okay. So, I hope that answered
the question.